Superhero movies are obviously fun to watch—their
continued success at the box office is proof
enough that audiences get a kick out of them.
Maybe it's because they've got a little something
for everyone—plenty of action, high-stakes
human drama, and even a few laughs laced into
the mix.
As it happens, there are often even more laughs
during filming than there are onscreen.
It's probably a combination of the set being
a high-tech playground and everyone getting
punchy from long shooting days, but whatever
the case, it makes for some really silly and
amusing superhero movie bloopers.
Daredevil
He may be blind, but Daredevil has other abilities
and heightened senses that make up for it.
Not among those abilities, it would seem,
is dominion over the sky and its many creatures—as
Ben Affleck discovered while filming a fight
scene in 2003's Daredevil.
While trying to perform his well-rehearsed
stunt choreography, he found himself unable
to quite pull it off because the birds that
were supposed to make the scene look cool
just kept running into him.
"Ugh!
Uh.
Dude, I couldn't…"
Superman
It's a risky business to employ child actors
in big budget movies, where saying the right
thing at the right time is kind of important.
In a scene from 1978's Superman, Jonathan
and Martha Kent have discovered toddler Superman
and are debating what to do with the presumably
lost or orphaned boy.
That's when the three-year-old thespian forgets
he's supposed to be acting ...
"We are going to find this boy's proper family."
"Oh, he hasn't got any.
Not around here, anyway."
"Yeah I do!"
Spider-Man 3
Spider-Man isn't cool.
Or at least Peter Parker, Spider-Man's mild-mannered
alter ego, isn't cool.
He's certainly no Bruce Wayne — he's lacking
the Dark Knight's suave self-possession.
That's why this blooper reel, in which Spider-Man
3 star Tobey Maguire is completely unable
to stop laughing while filming a normal, plot-building,
mundane scene, almost feels like it's in character—having
a laughing fit in a restaurant is so goofy,
it seems like something young, awkward Peter
Parker would do.
"We got it under control."
"Action."
"Hi, Peter!"
"Hi!"
Ant-Man
Of course there are going to be some bloopers,
riffs, outtakes, and cut scenes from a superhero
movie starring Paul Rudd.
He's a gifted, veteran comic actor, and he
brought a sense of fun and play to 2015's
Ant-Man—a movie that, at the time, was based
around one of Marvel's less mainstream characters.
Rudd, who usually stars in wild comedies and
small dramas, can't help but reflect on how
he's suddenly wearing a superhero suit in
a mega-budget action movie ...
"You talkin' to me?
You must be talkin' to me, cuz I'm the only
one here."
Deadpool
The dialogue is so self-referential and self-deprecating,
and Ryan Reynolds has such a witty, off-the-cuff
delivery, that almost the entirety of 2016's
Deadpool feels like it could have been improvised.
That's not to say that Reynolds didn't improvise
on set, because he did.
A lot.
One particular moment, though, seems to have
caught his costars completely off guard.
After all, it's in the middle of a fight scene
in the back of a speeding car—not generally
the type of place where a person breaks out
into an old Kenny Rogers song...
"Know when to fold 'em / Know when to walk
away / Know when to run…"
Spider-Man
Willem Dafoe is one of the finest dramatic
actors of his or any generation.
That doesn't mean he doesn't like to have
fun, as evidenced by his decision to play
the Green Goblin in 2002's Spider-Man.
He also likes to have fun riffing on set.
When filming what's supposed to be a dramatic,
tension-building moment in which the villain's
ire for Spider-Man threatens to boil over,
Dafoe started making a lot of angry noises—and
then some other noises ...
*OINK OINK OINK*
"Spider-Man!"
"Cut!"
Guardians of the Galaxy
There are a few ways for an actor to react
if their scene partner messes up.
They can remain silent, go back to their mark,
and try again.
They can also laugh uproariously.
Or they can stay in character and run with
the gag.
On the set of Guardians of the Galaxy, Michael
Rooker went with the latter option ...
"He was cargo!
And you boys are going soft on him."
"You walked us right off the set!"
"Yes, I did.
And I'm gonna do it again!"
Kick-Ass 2
Chloë Grace Moretz is a young actress, but
she's been working a long time and was already
a seasoned professional when she made 2013's
Kick-Ass 2, reprising her role as self-made
superhero Hit Girl.
In one outtake, Moretz delivers a line with
such conviction that nobody but the script
supervisor would've even known she'd muffed
it…
"Pull over, s--- breath.
Wrong line."
X-Men
The first X-Men movie was released in 2000,
long before the Marvel Cinematic Universe
was up and running with its various spinoffs,
team-ups, sequels, and crossovers.
Before that, superhero movies were generally
standalone affairs featuring just one comic
property.
So it's really silly and surprising when a
guy dressed as a certain web-slinger sneaks
into the lineup of super-powered mutants,
ready to fight ...
"I am completely in the wrong movie.
I am so sorry."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!